hey everyone today i'm going to show you
how to photograph couples hi my name is
jerry gionis i'm a wedding portrait and
fashion photographer
i've been photographing for 27 years and
teaching for 20. i'm going to share some
of that experience with you right now
and share with you how to photograph
couples and how to go from this
to this by the way i have this amazing
course the portrait quick start make
sure you click on the link below
or right up here and download it and
enjoy it for free
okay so you're going to photograph a
couple where do you begin where do you
start what do you do
now if you're inexperienced you've just
started perhaps maybe you haven't been
taught
in a way that's maybe a little bit
easier a bit more efficient you may
simply just want to go to the best
location and the lighting is what it is
because you might have a handsome couple
and you think great they're a handsome
couple
let's pick that nice tree let's pick
that nice wall
and guess what the lighting is really
bad we're going to simplify this for you
and give you a common denominator in
which to work from
for me i i will always pick beautiful
lighting
above a great location and you might
even ask what is beautiful lighting look
like
what does a good location look like can
we harmonize them together how do we do
it
first we're going to go outside and show
you
what a beautiful couple can look like
with bad lighting
okay so you see a nice little piece of
wall there we've got nice little
concrete we've got some rock
um but you know your first
instinct might be to simply just
photograph them against that wall so
let's see what that looks
like so guys i don't know just stand
there
see with couples photography it's funny
because couples are not going to always
be that graceful they're not always
going to sink in nicely
they might just get together in a poor
way but you have to add that little bit
of finesse if you want to look
above and beyond an everyday iphone
photographer
and that's okay you can get great shots
with an iphone but if you want to take
that next step and next level
you want to add a little bit of finesse
and that's really got to do with mainly
lighting
choosing the location that's
complementary finessing
their pose in a certain way and bringing
out the best of them as a couple
so now if you guys sort of get together
just to hug each other normally just
like you know
nothing to finessed and now let's
photograph you guys
and what i love about this shot
turn this way a little bit good just
there
is we have a decent location and we have
a really handsome couple
but this is what a a handsome couple
looks like with really bad lighting and
uh
rainy i've been photographing for years
and i love it when she looks
unattractive
and right now she does not look that
attractive but we have a nice location
we have to get that out of our minds
guys this is just not going to work
so remember always look for better
lighting
than a location so why doesn't this work
well if you look at the photograph we've
got the light hitting
on rainey's hair it's really not hitting
her face except for her nose so now her
nose looks a little bit more pronounced
the lighting is split lighting um uh
jacob
and even though that's okay you can
light him from one side and have shade
on the other he's squinting
he sort of can't really handle lighting
a little bit too the location looks
really good but they don't look good at
all
so what we have to do sorry about that
that was a little bit harsh
but we have to remember that lighting
and that's well here's what's happening
the sun's coming from up above
heading down low and the golden rule
with lighting is you just want to turn
the nose
or the chin whichever way you want to
remember it turn the nose and the chin
towards the light
it's always going to be more fruitful in
this case like i said if you were just
bringing out a couple and you
well photographing for the first time
you'll be tempted to shoot for just the
location
and i'm saying this is not what i call a
low-hanging fruit this is not an easy
way to photograph someone
even though the location might be nice
here's another way of actually
photographing them
so here we see the sun bouncing off the
ground
and then coming up here's what's going
to happen so you might say
okay well i know not to photograph them
in full sun and not that that's an issue
you can photograph in full sun and make
it look really good but we'll cover that
in another episode
let's get you guys actually in the in
the shade there of the garage door
okay so just there come a little bit
this way
good close the gap
actually you know what i'm going to get
you a bit more this way sorry guys a bit
more that way a bit more that way and
then turn
so that you're about over here like this
okay
so i'm not worried about the pose for
the moment i just want to prove my point
when it comes to lighting
okay
okay close the gap okay chin's up a
little bit looking at me hold it there
hold it
isaac good now if you look at this
you might be thinking well jerry that's
pretty good
um it's okay it's certainly better than
it was before in full sun
coming from the side what's happening
here is the sun is hitting the ground
and coming up now probably not so
obvious
on rainy but i find on jacob we're
getting those unflattering shadows on
the upper cheek bones
and also he's actually squinting quite a
bit now if you do want to photograph
someone in full sun or
in a place where they're looking off
into the sun what you want to do is you
want to close the eyes
try to relax the forehead say to your
subjects hey just don't anticipate the
sun because you'll already be squinting
just relax
on the count of three open up your eyes
one two three click
and then they can squint all day long
all they want all you want is a fraction
of a second
but still i'm not completely happy with
that kind of lighting
okay now you may have heard of back
lighting let's come this way
so we have a nice location
so logically we would just put them in
front of
those trees the bush whatever
just nice and close switch sides there
guys
good all right so we have a nice
location
nice little graduation portrait
high school sweethearts not really
but let's have a look okay so we're
gonna photograph them accordingly
let's have a look okay one two open
okay now why is this bad we have a great
location we have some nice highlights
falling on the on the bushes and the
trees
but when they were together if we look
closely um
we've got the sunlight hitting the back
of her hair because she's blonde that's
going to be a problem because we're
never going to get the exposure right
for her face
as in what how we want the face to look
to match the hair
and then they're standing um slightly
apart with him up a little bit
and half of his face or even a third of
his face is in sun
and we don't get a great exposure it
just doesn't look that great
so what we have to understand guys is
that
it's it's probably going to take you a
little bit of experience to be able to
photograph
and make these locations that were in
actually work for you
my advice is if you were asked to
photograph a couple whether it's with an
iphone
whether it's with a dslr or you're just
starting out
as a professional my advice is
warm up to a couple shots with a
lighting and a location
is a little bit more predictable that'll
be easier as you master that you can
keep on going
and then have some fun in sunlight open
shade things like that
so what we're going to do now we're
going to emulate shooting with window
light
by simply using the garage door that's
open and i'm going to basically be in
the garage
shooting against a non-descript
background and let's see
uh let's see us get some really cool
shots with a couple okay guys come over
here
okay so what is it perhaps an easier way
or a good place to start when you're in
an environment like this so i'm in my
driveway right now
and we mentioned if we look over there
again even from this perspective you can
sort of see how the sun
is behind the house here it's reflecting
off the ground and it is causing quite a
beautiful glow
up against the garage door now the
problem is
the lighting is coming from down low now
what we could do
is actually get our couple to lean
forward towards the light to correct
that light so we don't have those very
unflattering
shadows in the upper cheekbones now that
being said we can use the light a bit
more effectively
the sun's coming from behind the house
here it's actually bouncing off that rv
and then coming back this way therefore
because we've got a bit of a deeper
shadow
and the direction of light is coming
from more eye level
i feel that we're actually going to get
a better quality of light
and it's again like what i call a lower
common denominator
in terms of making it a little bit
easier for us so although this is what
we call open
shade as it's a shade of a building and
it's open we're not going to be shooting
in sunlight we're going to be shooting
in
shade what i want to do is have that
beautiful direction of light light
bouncing off that rv coming back here
and now once we've chosen that
particular location
now we can actually photograph our
couple which we'll do i'm going to get
you to
lean on here mate that's it
and now just angle this way a little bit
perfect and i want you to just basically
go in front of him you're going to
cuddle from behind
just a few little cobwebs there perfect
all right let's have a look
so give it a little cuddle from behind
your hands on his hands
now really important whenever you are
photographing a couple do you sort of
see how long her hair is
if i bring their faces together the hair
is interrupting the moment
okay so what we're going to do is this w
we could easily just flip the hair over
and possibly even get it behind her ears
exactly and i want you to sink your face
right on her face just there
beautiful okay good guys fantastic turn
your face into hers
so guys whenever i photograph a couple i
like to think of their faces their
bodies almost like two pieces of a
puzzle
fitting in together so if you've never
understood posing or read a start
simply ask yourself what is what does a
couple do well
they cuddle from behind like that they
cuddle from the front they kiss
they do all these different things so
liken it to your own relationship
and that gives you a great starting
point now you can very clearly see
let's see if i can compose this and show
you that the direction of light
is really cool here so let me go nice
and close so don't forget we're
photographing it
literally at a garage door
and i want to show you
okay so now you'll start to see the
shadows as i get a better exposure
let me come a little bit closer here
okay i'm cropping into his hair which i
quite like i'm cropping just underneath
her chin
and i'm actually using the the brown
edges
of the particular garage to frame them
and to keep yourself contained
but it's nice and close nice and
intimate now here's the cool thing if
you're looking closely at what i'm
seeing right now
you're very clearly seeing that i'm
shooting on the shadow side of her face
which is really really cool
gives it a beautiful depth and dimension
nice intimacy and so on
so what we'll do all right guys just
relax the eyes there a little bit close
your eyes just for a second to give
yourself a bit of a breather
eyes at me beautiful eyes will be mate
perfect now so you can do a safe shot
looking in the camera fantastic but
let's just add a bit more intimacy so
same thing again
now all i want you to do mate is just
overlap her face a little bit and turn
your face into hers
bit more good chin up a little bit look
like a turtle
chin forward a bit more and turn your
face more left
one more more good top of your head away
from me so look at me
so like this yeah and turn your face
that way and then
bring your face a little bit more
forward one second ready you're fine
that's it and then close the gap
good now jacob turn your face this way
good don't move
now why did i make those micro
adjustments i don't want his nose coming
right into his
into her eye that's going to look a
little bit weird and also i always get
my couples to mirror what i'm doing
so even though i try to describe what i
wanted so i turned like the top of your
head away from me
he didn't quite understand it so i
looked at him and i said i want you to
do this so
he quickly understood it so now
overlap her a little bit more the same
position so more of a turtle there mate
that's perfect
do you see how the bridge of his nose
frames her eyes perfectly
i love that now i want to move a little
bit this way because i had a little bit
of her
um earring on him which i don't want
so look into her lips there mate and
rainy eyes at me beautiful hold it
gorgeous eyes all the way down now
perfect hold it
beautiful and if we want to get rid of
some distraction you can sort of see
some strands of hair there
always watch that finesse guys watch
that little bit of finesse
that might interrupt that moment okay go
again
perfect
yeah that's looking better beautiful
hold it there for me hold it let me go a
little bit closer top of your head away
from me mate
there you go see now you know you know
so once you get it right once it's sort
of like it's easy to understand for the
rest of time
all right for the rest of humankind time
all right good hold it therefore you
hold it
eyes down again beautiful very nice
so i love that we've got a very
beautiful shot in a very simple
environment
this is just open shade of a building um
and
again remember whenever you're looking
at the sun hitting a building look the
opposite way
chances are there's going to be a
direction of light what i want you to do
is this
i always want you to look at your hand
okay so if you look at my hand here
do you see the iridescence of my hand
the saturation it's
there's a glow here all right so now
what happens is
watch what happens when i turn this way
now it's hitting in full sun
it's quite flat watch what happens when
i turn my hand
you see how you're seeing the creases in
my hand and the texture
and now you're seeing more shadow that
means it's going to be bad lighting
unless i was to tilt the face upwards
and as i turn it's only backlit but do
you see how
it's looking a little bit flatter but
when i turn this way
then i get more of a glow and guess what
that is where rainey's face was actually
turning into
perfect okay let's do a couple more
shots of our beautiful couple here
all right so how about we do something
um
let's switch sides so randy i want your
back on the wall there
and then turn your body towards me
perfect bring all your hair on this side
and i want you to go around and face her
properly
that's it and i want you to bring your
face sort of right over here next to her
ear as if
basically you're whispering in her ear
and she's doing the same with you so run
your chin up for me
turn your face this way bury your head
more inmate and if what i want you to do
mate is i actually want you to part your
feet
so you can get a little bit shorter
perfect
okay so rainy chin up you can close your
eyes and bring your arm right underneath
his armpit
that's it right underneath right
underneath up the back keep my going
beautiful and that left hand on the back
of his head now why are we doing this
because we're suggesting intimacy how do
you hug your partner well you would be
you would hug like that
often you you may whisper in the ear
like that you might kiss
on the cheek like that remember draw
inspiration from what you do with your
partner and if you have no partner
look at the movies look at romantic
movies how do they hug how do they kiss
look at the notebook look at how they're
kissing in the rain like there's endless
ideas
with what we have all around us do you
like the notebook
the movie i've never watched you've
never
seen the notebook oh that's just
terrible
that is um i don't know what to say i
can't even look at you right now
all right okay
so now what we're going to be doing is
we're going to frame them
um now i'm actually gonna frame them in
a bit of a slightly different way
remember guys we're shooting in a garage
door um
i quite like my frame being parallel
there perfect
now chin up rainy turn your face a touch
to the left
beautiful it's gorgeous those hands are
very really beautiful
now do me a favor there for me jacob i
want you to slide your hand a little bit
closer to me as in so off
off her waist so what i'm doing there
guys is i want to expose the thinnest
part of her waist i actually want to see
that little bit of a gap now she's
standing very flat-footed what i wanted
to do
she's going to actually bend the knee
that's closest to the camera that's
going to work
and then and that adds a bit more of a
hip and more of a curve which is really
beautiful
because i'm just basically seeing a
suggestion of that towards the bottom
perfect and now turn your face more left
there for me brainy
that's it good now she looks like she's
about to either kiss or whisper
in her in his ear um if i putt her lips
it's going to look like that's actually
happening so part the lips there
gorgeous hold it
beautiful and then he might want to say
something really funny and then she
starts giggling
beautiful very nice
it's funny how as soon as you actually
get them in a shot don't waste it
don't waste a shot i want you to take
the the shot that you were going for as
in being
single laser focus on that first one but
then ask yourself what could accompany
this photograph
it could just be that you're actually
getting a variety for some friends on
your iphone
it could be that you're working with a
dslr and you want to produce
a an album or some wall art for them
that's okay
but remember just take that extra shot
have some fun with them
don't waste the pose that you basically
did okay so now
i'm going to get him to turn his face
towards me so same position exactly
same position turn your face towards me
mate so half your face is hidden there
we go just like that perfect
good i love that that's awesome i love
it because it's sort of
almost it's almost voyeuristic right so
i want your eyes down there mate
and then rainy your eyes at me perfect
hold it there good let me just come back
a little bit
okay oh there we go again i'm just
basically composing so that i'm chopping
into his
the suit there okay you're looking into
her eyes at me there for me reigning
turn your face a little bit to the left
and what i want to do now too there's
just a little bit of a strand that's
coming here you've got your
superman little curl going on there good
hold it there good
oh we moved slightly i'll just fix that
a little bit good how did they hold it
eyes into her lips mate
good and then rainy looking down and
again i love the fact that
the bridge of his nose is framing her
eyes a bit of a giggle there guys nice
and happy beautiful very nice fantastic
i love that
they look great so
it's amazing how we can quickly get some
beautiful lighting
again being reflected off a building
rather than always bringing out a speed
light like a little a little flash
um or whether it's a big strobe or
whatever it may be but this is going to
be one of your lowest hanging fruits
here as well
let's just try a couple of full length
poses before we wrap up today's episode
and tutorial okay so what we'll do i'm
going to get your back side
right on the on the wall there for me
mate
okay so what i want you to do is bring
the back side on the wall but then bring
your feet further and i don't want you
to
lean back what happens when he leans
back um so ronnie if you just
come on the side there for a second a
few steps this way so we can see
when he leans back it just makes the gut
look a bit bigger when we
does this now he's a young guy he's a
handsome guy he hasn't had those
problems but
we have to be careful of that now if
you're going to bend a leg you want to
bend the leg that's closest to the
camera
so let's do that and then rainy come
around this side
and come nice and close this way rainey
in fact apart your feet mate something
gets rainy sort of to step right in
between
that's it um in fact rainy come put both
feet in between
that's it and pat your feet mate that's
it come back
now this is a good way to actually even
up the height difference as well in this
particular position
and now close the gap for me what i want
you to do here is put your hand out of
your pocket
and just relax that down a little bit
good you can see how she's putting all
her weight on her back leg
and then if we want to suggest a
romantic sort of pose and if his hand's
in his pocket
then the hand is saying i don't really
love you but it but he does right so we
need to work something out
so now we're going to bring the faces
close together i um
i want you to bring your hand on her
face as if you're
just about to guide a kiss for example
good
and now this hand again i want this hand
on his wrist
to almost say i love where that hand is
beautiful
okay hold it there now stay there ronnie
turn your face into hers mate
stop too much come back that's it i'll
adjust it accordingly
i'm going to shoot fuller length
again i'm only shooting on the on the
side of a house
i want to make sure that my frame
is going to work in this scenario so let
me
i'm going to have to drop this down a
little bit hold on
okay perfect all right so we've got some
more lighting what i want you to do
there
rainy just bend that knee a little bit
more perfect close the gap together
okay good chin um a bit of a turtle
there you go when i say turtle guys i'm
basically saying this
if we go back too much too much with our
chins we get this a turtle means
we bring it out and you can make the
sound it's more fun all right good hold
it there hold it
eyes into her into her chin there mate
good hold it
perfect give her a cute little kiss on
the forehead good very nice
nice and close now forward touching
again they're rainy with a beautiful
little look at me
chin forward mate again good hold it
there for me hold it stunning hold it
beautiful so now you can very clearly
see there's a direction of light now
i'm shooting her on what we call the
broad side of the face as in
the side of the face where the light's
coming from and she's turning her face
in this way causing a shadow on this
side
it really works for her but it was a
nice way of doing a full length shot but
again you sort of see how we're
isolating
the beauty within this location
so remember guys always pick the best
lighting rather than the best location
it's the lowest hanging fruit make it
make your life easier until you get a
bit more experience on how to shoot in
sunlight
and how to shoot with backlight and how
to shoot with reflector and different
things
the fact is that when you're
photographing a couple they're arguably
in love they're arguably well that's why
they're a couple right they're together
so you want to give them a little bit of
room to breathe and a room to play
so my advice is to go into open shade at
least to start off with until you get
more experienced
or it can actually even be into shooting
actually uh in window light
in a home where there's a strong
direction of light it's a big light
source
like we have here it becomes a nice and
easy way to photograph
now i was photographing at a speed of
320
which is a a very safe handheld speed
let alone the fact i'm on a tripod
f4 is going to give me a bit of depth of
field in other words how many things are
going to be in focus
which allows them to move a little bit
and i was shooting at 200 iso
but remember you have to start somewhere
my suggestion
start with some easier light until you
get more experience
have some fun with your couple and if
you're losing inspiration for posing and
what to do
simply ask them to do what you would do
with your partner hug them how do you
kiss how do you hold
all these different things enjoy and
remember repetition experience and
practice will be your best teacher
hey everyone thank you so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed that video
also do me a favor give me a thumbs up
please subscribe and don't forget to
click on that bell for notifications of
future episodes
also leave me a comment i'd love to hear
from you answer any of your questions
and stay connected and remember you
don't have to be the best
you just got to be better than last week
you